and the latest information and numbers i
have is uh 29
dead bodies
were found in in the channel
and it seems we still have
around five people to still missing
but we we have 20 united bodies and uh
we are still looking for uh
nationalities
and the
uh and to know if how many men women and
children are exactly
right so you're saying 29 um
yeah okay so um we were hearing 27 now
29 from you well and also do you have
any details on the sort of boat that
they were in what kind of boat was it
no i don't have in this kind of details
i don't even know if they had life
jackets up
so it's an awful tragedy
and
the question will be how can these
crossings be stopped they are coming
across in increasing numbers how can
this sort of thing be stopped
well
i think we
we all need both sides of the channel
to stop making of migrants um to stop
arguing around them and making them a
kind of internal policies and politics
arguments and trying to figure out
to find solutions because the channel is
right now
becoming
a new mediterranean seat like an open
sky graveyard
and um that
we must find stuff and hand end it
so we in france
need to and that's my message to the
french sovereign state to them few
minutes ago
we need to
to understand that if a migrant is in
calais or
around
the channel
is real is to cross the channel and
nothing will change so we need to
even by force for them to to go to some
kind of uh head center in the middle of
price but then i think the the
i was just going to say the french
police and the french border authorities
are saying they're doing their best is
there a case for accepting
an offer from the british government for
british police british border
force uh personnel to come across and
some sort of joint operation
i heard uh yesterday patel in the
comments
asking uh and claiming that she she
offered friends
common patrol and british troops even on
a french show that's not possible
because the question of sovereignty but
you know again if the people the
migrants are in calais it's great
because you may patrol with as many
soldiers as many police officers as many
john d'armary you want they will find a
way to cross
because you cannot monitor 200
kilometers of shore at the same time
that's not possible
day and night 24 7. that's not even well
to do it physically and
even with
as many people you want
so the only option here is first to make
sure that there is no illegal people
around the channel so that's our job in
the french parliament and that's what i
advocate for with the french authorities
and there is also responsibility for the
british government is to to give the
opportunity for the death migrants to
apply for asylum even if they are not
still in the uk because they take chris
just across to to apply for asylum and
that's it possible for them to make them
with the life just to apply for avalon
so
that's something we can both do
um
and just to to remember user figures uh
friends is processing 120 000
um as an application every year before
covet the uk were processing 40 000 uh
as an application so three times less
than friends that's not possible
because of the asylum
application process yeah so we all need
to to
find the solution all together
absolutely uh mr dumont you said that
you had no idea yet the authorities have
no idea yet on the nationality
of um the people involved in this but
but what what what do you think is that
the driving factor what is driving
this what is driving these people to
come across in such numbers
because they
first of all because smugglers
make them believe it's easier for them
to live in the uk
because if the other it is across
some borders the
the better the money for the smugglers
will be
so that's the first point the second
point is it's clear that the british way
of life in communities
the sudanese with the sudanese
afghanistan afghanis etc etc helps them
to believe
it will be easier for them even to live
without any id without any legal status
in the uk
and then
well it's the fact that
it's easier to find a job to find a
house to even to have some kind of
benefit in the uk if you are
undocumented comparative with friends as
an example to other continental european
countries so
if you had that the fact that a lot of
them speak english because well english
is a global language and a lot of them
are coming from former british colonies
as
iraq
has
sudan etc etc
it makes them all together that they
want to cause a child